los consumidores pasan a la acción
directa en el oeste de francia una
veintena de manifestantes bloqueó varios
depósitos de gasolina a pesar de que el
estado anunció una reducción de 15
céntimos por litro a partir del 1 de
abril los ciudadanos quieren más
estamos esperando la congelación de los
impuestos a los combustibles esto nos
permitiría respirar y recuperar el
aliento en nuestra vida diaria
la agencia internacional de energía
advierte de la posibilidad de la mayor
escasez de petróleo en décadas para
abandonar la dependencia con los
combustibles rusos los líderes europeos
buscan alternativas a dust coming
touring
tenemos que asegurarnos de que estamos
preparados que tomamos los pasos para
mitigarlo para ayudar a las personas con
el precio de la vida así un gran salto
hacia adelante en renovables más nuclear
el uso más efectivo de nuestros
hidrocarburos
murcia pero la crisis no sólo afecta a
occidente república democrática del
congo uno de los países más azotados por
la violencia y la pobreza depende
totalmente de las importaciones y el
petróleo este precios prohibitivos para
trabajadores como esté mototaxista
jabato expliqué a una potato en las
compañías petroleras no nos explican lo
que está pasando de sierra y al
siguiente día se abren con precios muy
altos el litro a 1 con 90
joanne n
es en los países más pobres donde antes
se están viendo las consecuencias de las
sanciones por la invasión de rusia
ucrania como en sri lanka donde la
multitud intentó asaltar la oficina del
presidente en medio de la ira por la
peor crisis financiera de su historia